[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by samantha hanratty
aka
misty quigley from yellowjackets if
you've not watched the first night
episodes make sure you watch those first
we're going to be talking a little bit
of spoilers and then come back to this
samantha how are you doing today i'm
good i'm so good how are you
good i don't think i've been this
excited for an interview in a long time
and that's also because obviously
because of your performance you crush it
but this show is addictive i think
everyone it's it's on society's mind
we're all hooked right now right so i've
i wish i could ask you a thousand
questions but i'm gonna ask what i think
yeah
okay all right we'll just knock them
through
all right we'll be here for three hours
either way we're good
we'll speed run them um so the thing i
want to know is that
you playing this character misty that
you're also sharing with an actress in
the caliber of christina richie
was there pressure to doing that number
one and did you guys have to get on the
same page about certain mannerisms and
stuff like that yeah oh my god i was
totally geeking out and very um i guess
intimidated in the beginning just
because i was such a big fan um and i
feel like the moment that i met
christina i was kind of put at ease um
because we were just talking wigs and it
was just kind of like we just kind of
dove right into you know we met during a
wig fitting so it was really just diving
straight into the misti
world and i think in the beginning i
definitely was kind of like you know
like oh i don't care whatever you guys
think you know type of deal because i'm
just like oh i don't want to step on
toes um but it was just really um
it was really cool to see that she had a
clear vision of where she wanted things
to go um it also kind of gave me that
same freedom to be like yeah like i have
a say in this and
we both have a very clear vision on who
misty is which is great
it's very collaborative and um it's
really i mean it's so special it's so
cool like i really like i feel like when
i watch as a fan of the show i'm like oh
my gosh we really do
co-exist as this character together it's
really it's really cool
yeah and it shows on the screen because
even as a fan watching it i don't even
feel the difference between going
between you guys i still think i was
seeing this what was that like that's so
cool
it's awesome and it's hard to pull off
and you guys do which is awesome and you
know you've mentioned before in other
interviews that you think misty thinks
very in the moment
can you kind of
maybe get into our headspace in a big
moment for her early in the season when
she destroys this black box like yeah
just give me a little bit of her kind of
logic there yeah if there is any yeah
yeah i think it's you know she kind of
she's
been doing all this chaos and all this
work and helping everybody um you know
during this after the plane crash um
and she finally has this moment to
herself she's about to go to the
bathroom and she overhears girls talking
behind her back um which she's heard her
entire life and for the first time ever
it's something positive
and
it's kind of like
this dream world that she's always hoped
to live in has finally come true and all
of a sudden there's an obstacle that
might get in the way of that and
it's
what do i do you know and in that moment
i think i don't think that she thought
i'm gonna strand us here forever i think
it really was just a
this is gonna get in the way of my
happiness right now so it's gotta go you
know
yeah so she took it out
i love that and i like that it's such a
simple idea and how she thought of that
that's that's a really good answer um
also on instagram you mentioned for the
last episode episode nine your favorite
scene of the episode was jackie putting
makeup on misty i also love this scene
um can you elaborate though why maybe it
is your favorite scene and kind of break
it down a bit for us yeah i think
all of us uh i'm not gonna speak for the
entire cast but i think we all kind of
talked about that um
one-on-one scenes are really nice in the
show because we do a lot of like
ensemble scenes so we do a lot of like
the big groups um so whenever we get
those one-on-one scenes it's always
quieter it's always um something where
you know we get to
experience our characters in a different
light and so i'd never worked with ella
one on one
we'd never had like that kind of moment
together and
um i think that it was just really sweet
like i read it and i was like i can't
wait to do this like this is just such a
sweet moment between these two um and
yeah i just i really liked it
yeah and
it was it was it was really great and it
also adds to like
how complicated some of these characters
are that maybe one person's doing
something you know we didn't see them
doing or vice versa
another reason it was like a favorite is
because when i'm in the headset of misty
i'm like
never would she have had the opportunity
to have like
the head girl like do her makeup you
know what i mean
it was just that kind of like
cool like thing getting to talk about
boys what she you know wanted to do and
i think it was just this one of my
favorite things about misty is when she
has those kind of like little
innocent like
like kind of girl moments um that i just
really enjoy
yeah no for sure and you mentioned her
thing about boys i do want to obviously
bring up coach ben here so
um it's one of the best things about the
show is the obsession with coach ben but
we see that she finds out he's gay this
episode is
is this all heartbreak for misty or is
there maybe some relief to her that it's
not just flat out rejection that maybe
she can justify it as oh he's just not
into
girls you know yeah i think
i'm i'm really curious on how things are
gonna play out um because all i've
thought
thus far while doing the scene was like
betrayal um but but i i really like that
idea of kind of like okay it's not me
you know and i can get through it type
of deal i'm really curious on which way
she's gonna go
um i'm not exactly sure
sometimes i i i'm a little scared of
what misty might do so um
we just have to wait and see
okay so it's interesting too you talking
about yourself and then talking about
misty how much when you when you went
into this character how much did you
find of yourself and misty or was it
someone who seemed very foreign to you
um
both like there are parts of her that
i'm like i don't yeah not at all um but
there are parts that we are so similar
like i'm i'm a very energetic person i'm
very like extra and like you know any
scene that i have where you know the
first time that you meet her when she's
like doing like the buzz buzz buzz like
cheering on like i remember everyone
being like oh my god sammy you have so
much energy and i'm just like yeah like
it's just you know it's fun and um
so i think that we both have a lot of
energy um and i think we both
uh care a lot about what people think um
i have a lot of insecurities as well
when it comes to you know how people
view me um and you know so of course i'm
an actor
putting myself out there for everyone to
judge
but uh but yeah no it's um we definitely
have some similarities but i think that
um misty uh needs needs a lot of help
too
sure and i love what you just said there
about you know putting yourself out
there for everyone to judge as an actor
which is why it is a brave art form but
also why you need an actress like
yourself who's willing to do that for
this character and you do
which is great um
but another thing too i think what gets
everyone so excited is seeing misty in
that winter timeline we see briefly in
the first episode now when you guys are
filming those scenes are they letting
you guys in on like okay what's really
happening during that timeline are you
guys kind of even a little out of the no
yeah so when we filmed the pilot which
was like you know over two years ago um
we filmed the pilot and i was the only
cast mate to go out into at the time we
were filming in mammoth um i was the
only one out of the cast to go there so
i only know
one person outside of me who they are um
yeah and so it was i was told who the
the antler queen was when i was out
there filming so i knew that from the
get-go which was cool um but besides
that i literally i'm like i don't know
who falls in the pit i don't know who
stands over the pit i don't know
anything i'm looking out like all the
other fans of like who's wearing what
and but they trick you because they're
like yeah but everyone's gonna start
borrowing each other's clothes
everyone's gonna start wearing each
other's things so sure you know you
might keep an eye out for a certain pair
of shoes but really it's going to be
passed along you know so
yeah and that that was the answer that
everyone right now is just leaning up
just listening trying to catch any
little thing you're saying yeah oh yeah
um but is that surreal to you too that
like you are not just in some regular
show you're in a show that
people are obsessed the reddit is like i
mean the biggest numbers i've seen in
years for a show and it reminds me from
what i relate to of like how lost had
that feeling where everyone just wants
it's a mystery right like how does that
make you feel are you ever kind of
checking out the reddit seeing what
people are writing every day i'm
checking every day i think this is like
the coolest thing to ever happen to my
career um i
feel like the luckiest person in the
world to be on a show like this and i
you know i'm like i'm a geek over
certain things like i'm a huge harry
potter nerd i'm a you know huge like um
survivor fan so like whenever i get into
something though like i love to know all
the details i love figuring it all out
so it's really cool to be on the other
side of things where you're on something
where you know some of the answers that
people are trying to figure out and um
it's it's really it's really cool and i
feel so so lucky and this is literally
all i've ever wanted in my career so i'm
just soaking it all in right now
oh that's that's so awesome to hear and
i'm happy for you it's cool and it's
exciting to see how you and the whole
cast are just embracing it and enjoying
it oh yeah there's there's like somebody
who who just put out two posters that
they made and i i tweeted about them but
i just bought both of their posters on
etsy like i'm like full-on fan mode as
well like i love that fan of the fans
yeah and i'm gonna say this you don't
have to agree with me right i really do
think misty is the most popular
character at the moment but without
people to be here for halloween like
that's yes you know oh yeah yes and also
people love caligula so
my question to you is there a chance or
can you please push for an origin story
of misty and caligula so we can see you
with this bird we want to know more i'll
tell you what i want i want me to out in
the wilderness connect with a bird and
that be like this this beginning of like
i want to be walking around with a giant
bird on my shoulder you know like that's
that's what i'm hoping for in in this
next
i think yeah that would be amazing we
just come full circle um so
i have to address two what is on
everybody's mind is that you have on
your wish list on twitch an oculus rift
vr gaming headset and hello natural
whitening fluoride toothpaste
does does this sum you up as a person
and have you gotten these things sent to
you yet and can we get them sent i'm not
i've not gotten them i would love them i
need to get back onto twitch first of
all um i haven't been on in a second but
yeah i i the toothpaste is a particular
brand because it's a vegan brand and so
yeah i i need i need a whole bunch of
more toothpaste
and um and you know that is a big ask
for the vr set so i didn't expect it but
i thought you know why not put it out
there it would be fun um but i am uh i
like video games i like gaming and i
think a vr set would be very fun
yeah no
on set like always has her vr stuff like
she's oh my god
yeah oh yeah like every time we all get
together sophie thatcher always has her
vr set
holy crap so you guys are you got a
little gaming crew here you are sitting
in a gaming chair as we speak so yeah i
know i'm in my fiance's room right now
it is in his office but yeah i have a
new gaming chair i've got all the
studio ghibli stuff and
well i'm excited that you're gonna have
about like a thousand vr headsets sent
to your house so enjoy
um now before i let you go can you maybe
give us you know obviously no spoilers
but maybe just a little tease for the
big finale on sunday like what we can
kind of
bring a box of tissues because it's the
finale you know we all know at the end
of a show
um
and
uh
pay attention to each and every detail
um
and
um oh my gosh some things are going to
be answered like you're really going to
get some answers um whether you want
them or not and
um and other things are going to leave
you with your jaw on the floor and
wanting so much more for next season and
i can't wait to start making that season
for you oh hell yeah and congrats on
getting it renewed i'm so happy it's
renewed i think everyone's waiting for
that news
oh man i'm sure it's gonna renew for
three and four before you know it so i
really hope so i wanna i
the idea
like even the idea of getting the misti
wig get put back on like i know i'm
gonna be emotional and crying like i
mean i can't wait to start actually
that's what i'm excited for on sunday is
starting to post all of like me just
bawling like i literally cried so hard
when we rapped because i was just so sad
to say goodbye to misty and not knowing
whether or not we were gonna be able to
do another season so i am so ready to go
back oh yeah and i think we're all like
you said getting the two shoes ready no
matter what happens in the finale we
have to say goodbye to you guys for a
little bit which sucks but everybody
take it in while it's happening watch l
jackets finale this sunday on showtime
and on the showtime app and watch
obviously samantha crush it as misty per
usual samantha thank you so much for
joining me and i hope to talk to you in
the future one day thank you so much
okay yes i'll talk to you next season
yes please
thank you